schönen guten morgen das bild live an
diesem donnerstag und gleich in der
breaking news ein munitionslager der
polizei steht in flammen hier in der
hauptstadt in berlin im grunewald da
sehen sie die rauchschwaden dort über
dem grunewald im süden berlins da knallt
seit den frühen morgenstunden kräftig
seit kurz vor 4 uhr immer wieder
detonation explosion damit sind die
berliner dort im süden der stadt heute
aufgewacht sie sehen dass diesen
großeinsatz der feuerwehr dort gerade
die bilder von unseren reportern
geschickt mehr als 100 feuerwehrleute
dort die den brand im grunewald
bekämpfen ein munitionslager und das
sind massive detonation schauen sie hier
das sind handy videos geschickt von
anwohnern dort das munitionslager
abgesperrt dort im wald durch diesen
zaun und dahinter kracht und knallt es
gewaltig nein das ist nicht das
feuerwerk der rolling stones am abend
wenn sie ganz kurz rein das sind massive
explosionen dort im süden der hauptstadt
das ist ein ganz beliebtes ausflugsziel
dort der südliche grunewald jetzt um
diese zeit da gehen die berliner dort
mit ihren hunden aus da machen sich die
erste auf den rädern unterwegs an der
havel und zum wannsee dort im grunewald
und dort eben jetzt dieser großbrand
noch unklar warum der ausgebrochen ist
wir haben gerade unsere reporter mit der
feuerwehr dort sprechen können was eine
mögliche brandursache sein könnte
die berliner feuerwehr wurde heute um 3
uhr 24 in den kronprinzessinnen weg in
nikolassee gerufen und dort die
gesprengt platz gewalt kam es zu
mehreren großen explosionen und kommt
immer noch zu explosionen
darüber hinaus kam es zu einem brand der
sich sehr zügig auch aufgrund der
trockenen vegetation auf den umliegenden
wald bereich ausbreitete die
ersteintreffenden kräfte konnten die
lage schnell bestätigen und zügig groß
nachalarmieren zogen sich dann aber
zurück auch aufgrund der massiven
explosionsgefahr des bang platz ist da
dort immer noch viele kampfmittel lagern
also ein munitionslager in der
hauptstadt hier in berlin ein
munitionslager der polizei steht in
flammen seit den frühen morgenstunden
seit etwa 4 uhr das jetzt in diesen
morgendlichen stunden die rauchschwaden
dort im süden berlins über den grunewald
und das ganze hat noch eine geschichte
nicht nur diese massiven explosion und
die dotation nein im süden berlins ist
gerade auf den straßen alles gesperrt
die abos die autobahn wegen dieser
massiven detonation die führt direkt
dort hinter dem zaun lang die autobahn
auf der anderen seite und die ist
aktuell gesperrt im berufsverkehr
bedeutet das eine menge ärger umsteigen
auf die s-bahn ist für die berliner
aktuell nicht auch die s bahn dort im
süden die fällt teilweise aus also das
beschäftigt im moment die hauptstadt
dieser massive brand dort im süden
berlins in einem polizei munitionslager
kurz vor 4 uhr war das immer wieder
detonation explosion da sind die
berliner mit diesen geräuschen heute
aufgewacht im süden der stadt das ging
tatsächlich überstunden schauen sie hier
das ist gedreht von anwohnern dort
direkt am zaun zu diesem munitionslager
alles was dahinter ist ist dieses
riesige spreng gelände der polizei da
lagern 50 tonnen weltkriegsmunition und
illegales feuerwerk normalerweise wird
das kontrolliert dort immer wieder
gesprengt man kennt das das ist immer
wieder knallt dort im grunewald und
heute eben außer kontrolle dort
wahrscheinlich wegen das war
vorher in berliner grunewald nach einer
unbeabsichtigten explosion auf einem
sprengplatz im stadtteil zehlendorf ist
in der nacht zum donnerstag ein feuer
ausgebrochen durch die anhaltende dürre
breiten sich die flammen schnell auf
einen nahe gelegenen wald aus der
einsatz der rettungskräfte wird durch
zahlreiche explosionen erschwert die
feuerwehr kommt nicht an den
eigentlichen brandherd und musik deshalb
darauf konzentrieren eine weitere
ausbreitung der flammen zu verhindern
die lage ist immer noch unübersichtlich
zurzeit gucken wir wir haben einen
radius von 1000 metern den sich keiner
nähern darf unser einsatzkräfte nicht
wie auch die bevölkerung hier auch
nochmal die information dahingehend an
die bürger auch mit dem schönen wetter
was wir verstehen können wir versuchen
die brandbekämpfung von allen seiten
anzufangen anzufangen und das auch vom
wasser mit lösch boten hier auch der
lösch-hubschrauber die schwierigkeit ist
die warmen temperaturen die
körperliche belastung für unsere
einsatzkräfte hier aber auch ganz klar
die vegetation das feuer schreitet im
moment unkoordiniert voran wir können
nicht mehr an als die 1000 meter
versuchen ist eine riegelstellung
aufzubauen zum glück sind keine personen
oder hier auch wohngebäude betroffen in
enger zusammenarbeit mit der polizei und
bundeswehr die auch gepanzerte
spezialfahrzeuge haben versuchen wir nun
den löschangriff langsam vorzunehmen
dieses wird sich aber dann doch noch
über mindestens den ganzen tag
herauszögern die feuerwehr ist mit mehr
als 100 einsatzkräften vor ort auch
spezialkräfte der bundeswehr wurden
angefordert
verletzt wurde bisher niemand auch
wohngebiete befinden sich nicht in
unmittelbarer nähe allerdings sind die
explosionen über kilometer zurück wie es
zu der explosion gekommen ist ist noch
unklar auf dem platz wird iv und
munition gelagert und durch den
kampfmittelbeseitigungsdienst der
berliner polizei kontrolliert entschärft
also ein mega feier jetzt gerade in
diesen momenten in der hauptstadt
ausgebrochen am frühen morgen in der
nacht hat es noch geknallt gegen du bist
davon wach geworden hat das gehört habe
ich dann gezwungen weiter zu schlagen
das war heftig man hat die erschütterung
tatsächlich gespürt hier im süden
berlins das ist ein riesiges gelände
dort im grunewald total beliebtes gebiet
vor allen dingen für alle die den hund
haben das ist jetzt so die zeit da gehen
alle berliner dort im süden die
freihaben raus mit den hunden heute
nicht dass es weiträumig abgesperrt sie
sehen wie es da außer vor wenigen
stunden und wir haben ja gerade von
polizei und feuerwehr gehört das ist bei
weitem nicht unter kontrolle hat sich
logischerweise keiner drauf auf das
gelände weil halt dauern noch was in die
luft fliegt dort wir sprechen gleich mit
unseren kollegen benjamin kampf der ist
die ganze zeit dort vor ort und der
bringt uns auf dem laufenden im moment
breitet sich das feuer breiten sich die
flammen dort weiter aus die polizei und
die feuerwehr durch sprechen im moment
von einem unkoordinierten feuer also das
ist einfach etwas sperrige begriff dafür
aber bedeutet eben da ist nichts unter
kontrolle und die fahren immer mehr
gerät auf mittlerweile schwere
räumpanzer dort wasserwerfer aufgefahren
wir hören sogar dass die bundeswehr um
hilfe gebeten wurde weil das eben ein
munitions gebieten hoch gefährliches
gebiet dort ist unser reporter ist jetzt
dort hinter dem zaun benjamin traf unser
bild reporter der das seit den frühen
morgenstunden dort verfolgt das hat mir
ehrlich gesagt habe ein bisschen angst
gemacht dass die feuerwehr nach so
vielen stunden sagt das ist
unkoordinierten kommen da gar nicht ran
wir können uns das aus der luft
irgendwie angucken ist das ein eindruck
dort von den einsatzkräften bei denen du
dich da gerade befindest benjamin
es ist tatsächlich der fall dass die
feuerwehr keine chance hat sich etwas
dich dann noch an diesen brandherd heran
zu tasten es ist ein umkreis von 1000
metern geschaffen worden es ist zu
gefährlich und deshalb ihr habt es auch
gerade eben angesprochen ist auch die
bundeswehr angefordert worden weil die
kennt sich aus mit unwegsamen gelände
die kommt jetzt hier mit stark
gepanzerten fahrzeug an die rollen hier
vor gleich in wenigen minuten soll es
dann soweit sein die können dann wie im
kriegsfall sich dann tatsächlich immer
dichter an diesen brandherd rantasten
und sind dann zum einen fahrzeug
technisch geschützt und natürlich auch
das personal selbst geschützt weil die
normalen feuerwehrautos die polizei die
wasserwerfer
die würden derartige explosionen
detonationen nicht wegstecken können
denn beschreibt uns einmal den grunewald
für all die die nicht aus der hauptstadt
gekommen die den grünewald nicht kennen
wie bedrohlich ist die situation gibt es
da wohnen gegen denn in der nähe derzeit
breitet sich das feuer jahr weiterhin
unkontrolliert aus kann das gefährlich
werden irgendwann für anwohner
momentan brennen hier wohl 15.000
quadratmeter 1,5 hektar das sind
umgerechnet circa zwei fußballfelder die
hier seit den frühen morgenstunden
brennen hier werden 50 tonnen
weltkriegsbomben gelagert darunter auch
noch illegales feuerwerk was dann hier
zu gegebener stunde kontrolliert
gesprengt wird das werden die berliner
das werden die brandenburger kennen wenn
die avus hier im bereich hüttenweg dann
immer mal wieder in den sommermonaten
für ein paar minuten gesperrt wird damit
es hier zu diesen kontrollierten
sprengungen kommen kann glücklicherweise
befindet sich dieses munitionslager der
polizei im grunewald selbst also es sind
in den letzten stunden keinerlei
personen zu schaden gekommen und auch
kein wohngebiet nicht ohne grund
befindet sich dieses munitionslager
mitten im grunewald damit so etwas
tatsächlich ausgeschlossen werden können
die flammen breiten sich ringförmig aus
die feuerwehr ist mit drohnen im einsatz
versucht sich jetzt ein bild aus der
luft zu verschaffen die tasten sich
jetzt also ran versuchen die weitere
lage zu besprechen lösch hubschrauber
sind angefordert auch die neben der
feuerwehr die bundeswehr und das
passiert dann alles hier in den nächsten
stunden lösch panzer sind schon vor ort
und wie gesagt löschhubschrauber und
bundeswehr das kommt jetzt alles in den
nächsten minuten bis stunden ja das kann
uns den ganzen tag beschäftigen also
immer noch bei weitem nicht kontrolliert
die lage dort im berliner süden bei
diesem mega feier dort auf diesem
munitionslager gelände benjamin du hast
es gesagt mehr als zwei fußballfelder
groß das gelände das der brennt seit den
frühen morgenstunden das ist ein
riesiges gelände aber vor allen dingen
das hauptproblem eben wasserlage hat
eine 50 tonnen weltkriegsmunition
und offenbar ja illegales feuerwerk in
großen großen mengen benjamin
richtig genau das ist die problematik
vor der die polizei steht vor der die
feuerwehr steht die hier seit vier uhr
morgens versucht diesem brand irgendwie
herr zu werden wir sehen jetzt hier
fahrzeuge vom thw wir sehen die berliner
feuerwehr
wir sehen im weiteren verlauf hinten
sind die autos die gepanzerten
löschfahrzeuge der polizei bereits durch
gefahren gepanzertes fahrzeug der
polizei hier auch noch in grün steht
nach wie vor hier vor ort also sobald es
da grünes licht gibt sobald es da mehr
informationen über die drohnen bilder
gibt mit der die feuerwehr hier zur
stunde im einsatz ist rückt hier nach
und nach mehr gerät nach vorne jetzt
halt erst einmal die bundeswehr weil es
zur stunde tatsächlich viel zu
gefährlich ist sowohl für die
einsatzkräfte als auch für die leute die
hier vor ort sind und sich dann stück
für stück hat in dieses brandgebiet
bewegen müssen um dem vorzubeugen wurde
jetzt wie gesagt die löschhubschrauber
angefordert und auch die bundeswehr wenn
ihr mit vielen herzlichen dank dir für
deine informationen bewusst natürlich im
laufe der sendung immer auf dem
laufenden halten was war passiert bei
diesem großbrand im grunewald danken
[Musik]